[Music]
I hereby arrest you for crimes against
the sacred timeline doing the old recap
I see come on I don't need a previously
on for a show that last AED over a year
ago well I stand corrected let's see
here we've got Loki looking handsome in
a shirt and tie and thinking damn I'm
hot while looking at hologram of himself
yeah that checks out then we have Loki
looking handsome in a shirt and tie
while spitting some truth to Mobius yeah
I dig that and finally we have Loki
looking handsome in a shirt and tie
while hanging with the equally handsome
leather clad lady Loki as Kang makes fun
hand gestures great everything's exactly
as I remember it and I won't have any
issues whatsoever understanding what's
happening and why I should care ah
sudden Kang the concrete Loki just
exited the right of the frame to jump
over the railing that was to his left
and I'll spend the next few decades
thinking about what transpired the brief
moment the camera wasn't on him sure
he's as guardian but that Lebo Faith was
so easily survived I'm wondering why
ever takes the stairs does this flying
truck not have air brakes or reverse
thrusters or what I'm trying to say is
it's going too fast you got hit by a
Loki and then ran into a statue you're
not momentum in correctly also I'm glad
to see the Casey's unscathed but with
that kind of proximity to this window
I'd have expected him to be a Glass
Cactus right about now also also the
flying truck crashes into a different
floor of the building that Loki needs to
be on just in time for his plot luck
dinner
should be fine we actually heard the
vehicle thud but it's flying in the
background here why is thud we'll find
out that these vronos veins are a
problem for the temporal garment
industry because of a lack of space-time
infrastructure this season's taking a
deep dive into Logistics exactly what we
wanted from a show about the god of
Mischief he disappeared right in front
of me actually he disappeared right
behind you can I help you with something
X5 if you're wondering if this character
was in season 1 I'm here to assure you
that I'm wondering the same thing you
know the funny think about jet skis
everyone thinks that it's a personal
watercraft and it's actually a brand
same way Kleenex is so Kleenex is a
brand of personal watercraft the line
really cleared it up for me
thanks I don't care why' you ask
technically you did not ask for your fun
facts regarding Kleenex brand jet skis
but he did ask this one here is this on
the sacred timeline to which a simple
answer would have been
yes inditing office Culture by
pretending everyone here is too dead
inside to react to someone violently
timed traveling obvious I was just doing
my job if you're wondering if this
character was in season 1 I'm here to
assure you that I am wondering the same
thing no one in production thought about
Loki's staff lining up with King's mouth
in this shot or did they make it make
sense Marvel's one line of instruction
after making a new director complete
orientation by watching the entirety of
the MCU somehow makes it into the
episode should I care that this guy is
asleep cuz I don't I might later because
of some timey wiy nonsense but that
would be a branched reality meaning in
this one I still wouldn't care some guy
appears out of thin air and not 30
seconds later you're so bored with him
that he can sneak up on you and steal
your weapon we're pruning Frescas now
what's next tapestries valances sconces
where does it end it was a draw you both
kicked each other through time doors
simultaneously Mobius would be excellent
at TV S I need a low key roomat so we
need to address the fact that you keep
disappearing but do you we'll soon see
Loki solving his present problems in the
past and even after that no one stops to
say hey wait a second this is actually
pretty useful in this episode the
duration of Loki's time travel seems to
be directly linked to however long the
plot needs him to be in a given place in
this instance he has a quick pop out and
back just for the fun banter of it
pretty arrogant it's like calling
yourself last man standing shots fired
somewhere Tim Allen's calling his
lawyers and grunting at them about
trademark
disputes smartest person in the show is
toiling away in the obscurity of the
basement basement cliche but also that
person is being played by the revivified
ever vesence that is kiwi Kuan I take
back all the sins everywhere all at once
if I wasn't sure wouldn't break the
simper loom I guess I'll just have to
settle for the one how long has it been
uh could it be three or four 400 years
episode feels like the series realized
the limitation of time not working like
that here in the last season so they
decided to suddenly rcon centries of
time into this season that do indeed
work like that here is he talking to you
in the pass and you're just now
remembering it wow that makes perfect
sense there's no flaw in that logic I
don't know how to sin this they're doing
time travel [__] while immediately
acknowledging it's time travel [__]
it's so self-aware of its [__] that
it's trying to put me out of work and
that makes me angry and when I get angry
I start sinning first off someone in the
time you want to end up in would need a
temporal Aura extractor oh who see
what's a thing of a doodle I know all
about those have you heard about how if
you fall into black hole you turn into
spaghetti no good the less you know
about that the better there are probably
other things to know about that like why
is it spaghetti and not Linguini or pine
but I doubt that would make him feel any
worse about the whole Affair well I
guess you two are ready to go Loki's
time slipping enables them to quickly
solve the time slipping problem dooming
us to infinitely Ponder how Loki's
actions in the past have altered this
timeline because time does work like
that here now what's the quality of life
with no skin death in most cases and
pain in all the others stop making me
find out these things Patrick Stewart
isn't on the other side of this door in
this scene the temporal Loom is the
heart of the TVA it's where raw time is
refined into physical timelines time
[__] no really it's obvious they
created this thing just for this season
if not for just this episode and I'm
frustrated because the first time I
heard this I went oh that makes sense
can't just have raw time going wherever
it wants it looks like a
disaster it is a disaster okay if you
say so to fix Loki's time slipping
you'll go out there and launch the
extractor which will pull Loki from the
time stream before I need to close the
blast doors well that certainly was a
contrived mess of random that they have
to do to make Loki less time slippy and
more time sticky this timer is sink to
the loop I can now see that OB is going
to be the cue of this double o key
situation you've got about an
hour you've got about 5 minutes
acknowledging that your ticking clocks
are arbitrary if I didn't make it back I
make it back right but when I use this
thing I might not make it it's so cute
that Loki doesn't know he's the main
character also this pruning stick
doesn't go with him so his clothes
shouldn't go with him either I mean and
the ticking clock not just the clothes
but the ticking clock as well it's the
future check off's touching of dead skin
cells how the hell am I going to hoof it
in this you got to or what what do you
mean or what that kind of Temple energy
will peel the skin right off you and
Mobius will lose all of his skin how
many times does this man have to tell
you you're going to be skinned alive sir
that is not hoofing it that's barely
even bumbling in a stumbling I know
everyone's running for their life but I
still would to triy to Yo anyone got a
Time stick to some of the people running
past you're lost Loki ask for directions
mobus you have 30 seconds since you like
giving out ticking clocks could you at
least let me know how much longer my Hot
Pockets have to go in the
microwave
I desperately need a Time stick to prune
myself but wait a second is that a phone
ringing man that's so creepy let me
slowly walk towards it there is nothing
you can do for him he's lost to time no
he's in the future you not knowing where
he is does not make him lost taking an
elevator during an emergency punyod Loki
shooting out of this time machine right
now is a literal Dex Mischa x makina
Hunter B5 said she' take care of General
docs which apparently meant just
standing back and being a bystander with
that logic in mind I've taken care of so
many things in my life I have been
getting done all this for Sylvie you
mean the time variant who's killed
scores of your colleagues and alluded
capture so effectively that the TVA
decided to enlist an alternative version
of her to Aid in her capture yeah seems
reasonable to me okay Marvel I've provu
ramblings you've scrolled across these
Post-it notes and I have found that I
don't care I want to try everything
after all the struggles she's been
through in her life episode put Sylvie
through the gastrointestinal effects of
the 80s McDonald's
menu I keep the skin peeling otherwise
the little follicles don't have a chance
to breathe you
know just had an accident yes I know I
just had an accident you Daffy bastard
jet skis seos one of these calling your
name obus I don't know about
calling cuz I ran my jet ski into a
chipot
play this tape will self-destruct in 5
seconds oh the sky is far M this changes
everything gentlemen you can't fight in
here this is the War Room Li what's the
quality of life with no skin well cold
little hungry we're having power surges
all through the TVA did you just say to
me is it arrogant if you can back it up
well can you back it up yeah that's
scary he's all River Dance all the time